question qu'attendez vous de moi je peux
les sept principes nicolas batum ont pas
patron pas trop expliquer ce qu'on fait
à nicolas batum et aux téléspectateurs
qu'ils nous rejoignent
je m'intéresse à tout ce qu'on voit pas
dans les missions des images of et je
révèle le vrai caractère des gens qui
sont autour de cette table est et vous
allez voir c'est hélas
exceptionnellement j'étais je voulais
dire que j'étais très touché par ce qu'a
dit jean michel il a dit que je vais
impressionné donc je vais lever le pied
sera très bientôt
exceptionnellement aujourd'hui elle est
tout juste une question vous êtes moteur
je m'appelle gars très souvent vous
mangerez jean michel mr dire du mal de
ses collègues pourquoi est il si méchant
avec tout le monde et ce à cause de son
petit zizi
c'est une très bonne question que vous
posez là odette pourquoi jean michel est
il si méchant déjà me concernant moi qui
ai fait tout le temps de le mettre en
valeur
j'ai l'impression qu'ils m'aiment pas
vrai dilemme personnes non mais moi
particulièrement regardé le canton
présente de la bande
celui qui nous fait rire oui jean luc
lemoine
les champs c'est méchant s'agit mi
lourds
non il ya quelque chose je vous assure
c'est pas la paranoïa un autre exemple
je voulais faire une photo avec mes
camarades fallait camarades de mon côté
un petit jeune fille résultat le
commentaire le plus gratuit de l'année
113 leur championnat qui sont hébergés
réponse vous dit des conneries pas cessé
savez vous pourquoi des conneries
pendant la seconde mais c'est ça allez
bon et voulais juste dire que j'étais
gay bon c'est pas grave quand c'est sur
moi le vrai problème c'est quand ils
s'en prennent aux invités ya quelques
semaines nous recevions le grand jean
reno qui à votre demande cyril à effet
son lot d'excès et quitter le plateau
une performance qui a bluffé j'en ai mis
assez le pire et c'est le pire de tous
les gouvernants c'est le pire depuis je
vais vous dire mais c'est en fumée comme
les [ __ ] tu veux raconter ce matin
encore il m'a menti jean luc istin des
antilles dont il aurait pas osé c'est
vrai qu'est ce qu'il a fait parce que ce
matin je vous dit où je vais appeler
jeudi voilà jean michel je crois que tu
travailles la radio pendant l'émission
et je lui dis je vois que tu écris il
dit mais pas du tout j'écris des trucs
pour l'émission de télé et là j'ai dit
ah oui j ai consulté tous les cas petit
avion luc lemoine et j'ai regardé sur
les caméras et tu travailles la radio on
l'a vu il dit oui c'est vrai mais pas
pas tout le temps si je t'ai vue de
faire 10 3 10 ou 12 fois oui c'est vrai
mais je le ferai plus
cet inventeur bagages à vous régaler
pourquoi vous êtes un menteur comme ça
s'est passé c'est naturel chez m
on a bien comment on aime bien on aime
bien donc ça mérite une récompense
toutes ces gentillesses karim savez jean
michel c'est avant tout la chanson et
l'élégance et vous allez voir que celui
qui se décrit lui-même comme un homme
moderne est vraiment toujours tiré à
quatre épingles
m
comme ça
il espère venir
ils sont et où katy perry je sais c'est
pas sympa de montrer ça mais en même
temps ça se fait pas de vanille de stars
internationales comme jean reno arrêt
est encore bon jour un énoncé rien par
rapport à ce qu'il a dit sur nolwenn
leroy non si tant il fait savoir thierry
moreau et foot cet artiste ah oui alors
quand dale oen est venu nous voir
il est parti la queue hier à l'entrée
d'autres plateaux et jean michel a fait
sa grosse daluz
ses rivaux
robuchon hd
voir
avec moi j'écoute
comment
est-ce qu'on peut pas dire qu'on a un
peu on sème on est des frères au centre
est
ce qui doit partir je vais bien voir sa
prévention thapelo toute chose comme ça
ce sera fait ça fait vraiment pas alors
tout de suite une autre aventure de jean
michel
est-il
c'est ponctuel bras cassés aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est sa fête à il se fait
reboot
allez on va passer à quelqu'un d'autre
un nom aussi parce que la force de
l'équipe de touche pas à mon poste c'est
d'avoir su associer des gens très
différents dans tous les domaines
oui enora isabelle par exemple elles
n'ont pas les mêmes goûts musicaux et
pas la même attitude non plus une gueule
l'autre est plus discrète je vous laisse
deviner qui est qui j'ai pas l'idée mois
moi je sais pas mais le plus drôle dans
l'extrait suivant c'est kenora ne va pas
voir isabelle dans son dos dire qu'elle
aime ce qu'elle entend enfin je pense
sinon on n'aurait peut-être pas lâcher
sa la fin
non c'est de la merde
qualifié pour isabelle chagnon s'est
passé juste un mot malheureux ça ça
arrive aux meilleurs
par exemple cyril vacances rires il
essaie d'arranger les choses
ça peut déraper la gérard louvin se paie
dit que jean michel et thierry se moque
toujours de son âge
excusez moi aller prendre un verre les
deux là girard laisse laissé d'écrit
parmi celles dont on est bien d'accord
les deux sont cons sauf jean michel un
peu maladroit c'est pas beau c'est beau
c'est pas facile au rôle de cyril un il
doit être à la fois animateur médiateur
et protecteur donc il est très vigilant
et son équipe
regardez là il discute avec enora et moi
mais en même temps du coin de l'oeil
il va voir qu'à côté bat gilles verdez
n'a pas l'air dans son assiette et en un
quart de seconde
elle va cerner le problème est posé la
question que tout le monde se poserait
août
le plus magique si la can pris le temps
de réponse sa part assuré bercy j'y
viens en tout cas j'ai un contrat pro
laïque gide
ah là là quand il ne va pas bien qu'est
ce que je fais je suis pas cinéaste de
son étoile préféré à son astre enora
malagré ah oui aujourd'hui dans cet
épisode toujours aussi sensuelle et nora
expliqua bertrand le secret de sa
coiffure du jour a comme ça
et ça ça c'était jour j'étais pas là dit
le maître des couilles quand même c'est
amical je me suis inquiété pour un ami
vous êtes ici c'était amical on allait
désole gilles 1 c'est bertrand qui a
cassé la vieille chatte dhainaut
il évoqué tout à l'heure stanislas
wawrinka était venu nous voir dans
l'émission de joueur de tennis à la
troisième mondiale exactement ça lui a
porté bonheur à roland-garros et sa
périphérie le défi au ping pong
alors on va pas se mentir syrie c'est
notre fierté notre gladiateurs
invincible et toute l'équipe est
derrière lui quand il est en plateau
quand il joue dans le hall autre chose
parce qu on oublie que les micros reste
ouvert alors ça a été diffusé en direct
dans l'émission n'ont eu qu'un numéro
trois mondial voilà on est moi ça me
dégoûte faudra qui paiera les supporters
c'est bien mais c'est tellement un
connard la meuf va très très loin ça
veut dire bah ça c'était pour rire oui
bah oui mais c'est sympa quand même et
ses rêves ou gagner tout le temps c'est
insupportable ça ça m'énerve que vous
gagnez tout le temps et nous les dix
faut faire mission ça m'a fait rire bah
oui il faut se contrôler en permanence
cette émission parce que tout est
récupéré oui bah ça mais sans âme on
peut se faire comprendre par exemple des
grands chênes droit alors que je disais
un tweet qui rendait hommage aux filles
de l'équipe regardez il ya beaucoup de
gens qui réagissent ce qu'ils lisent
il y a trop de perfection on touche pas
à mon poste enora isabelle et valérie
sont rayonnantes
alors vous savez nous nous faisons
beaucoup de jeu dans cette édition
demande souvent si nous prenons tout ça
au sérieux
sinon si nous avons vraiment envie de
passer un week end chez série puisque
c'est le prix à la fin de l'année mais
bah oui c'est vrai alors moi perso ne
bute pas tant que ça par contre y en a
d'autres ils ont très premier degré non
voici le moment moi monsieur mathieu
qu'arrive-t-il aux anges de la télé
réalité après la diffusion d'un épisode
sans fautes de français
mais non
on m'a dit qu'il allait alors vous allez
travailler la terre si cette série-là
fond dans le jeu bercy thierry voilà
c'est beaucoup et dérapages aleri aussi
venir chercher je savais qu'avec vous
savez qu'en ce moment on voyait et une
fissure entre nous en passons parce que
je sais pas pour qui veulent venir chez
vous comme il doit se faire chier chez
eux c'est sur malouda ils sont ils ont
très joué un peu dans l'hôtel veut
quitter un peu pas tâche aussi ça va
nous faire du bien on peut comprendre ça
oui mais ils sont treize jours parce que
ce qui est possible à des grands jeux de
l'équipe faut le savoir ces deux volets
les portables des autres là c'est jean
michel qui en faisait les frais et qui à
cause de limites aux maquilleuses va
honteusement accusé son camarade thierry
moreau attention les masques vont tomber
jean-michel regarde bien les pourritures
vont se révéler
me
et puis la minute
le sport en fête et
on a aimé le garder leurs bêtes chéri
d'ailleurs senti comme ça mais c'est le
pire
franchement ça se fait pas de voler un
portable un cyril bah oui vous vous
feriez pas ça non surtout pas par
exemple que sa carrière non on va
vérifier quand même
oh [ __ ] c'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
qu'il avait cinq jolies il envoyait un
sms à claire keim
on attend quoi
c'est forcément très sec je vais te
montrer moto dur
et depuis bixente lizarazu a pété la
gueule et je vais vous raconter
l'histoire parce que je peux raconter la
suisse qui paraît qu'elle a reçu un sms
et ils étaient ensemble et donc ils
voient ils voient donc le téléphone
vibre et du fait c'est qui est claire
rien revenons sur un sujet aussi une
connerie parce qu'elle boit christophe
carrière j'ai envie de te montrer mon
zizi tout dur voilà donc 6 mai cnt nous
regarde c'est rien voilà c'est
christophe carrière et en plus il n'a
jamais existé tout dur c'était à
préciser deux questions est oui
d'autres questions bonjour je m'appelle
georges j'aime la bonne humeur de votre
émission comment faites-vous pour
arriver à ce résultat
est ce que vous buvez beaucoup avant la
question posée la journée mais pas du
tout sinon nous ne pourrions pas être
aussi précis dans cette émission
mais si vous aimez l'alcool et l'effet
que ça peut avoir sur les animateurs
télé je vous ai ralenti quelques images
pour vous vous rendez compte de ce que
ça donnerait si nous pouvions vraiment
adverse alors allah nous parlions de
l'émission de laurent delahousse
consacrée à dominique strauss kahn tout
de suite touche pas à mon poste version
bourg est assez bon
après tout les fans devaient dire oui et
bien et le présentateur bouge pas et
aimant et s'attend même ses gosses broc
maire isabelle morini-bosc bout est-ce
que c'est vrai a dit trahi et je peux
vous avez rencontré dsk et keane il a su
combien votre chat a marre parce qu'on
est ensemble estime meeting tout ce qui
m'est qui n'est tout ce qui passait mais
mais bon ça sert mais il vous a vraiment
proposer quelque chose